hello I'm Masahiro Sakurai from Sora
limited here at the Nintendo digital
event I'd like to lead off by talking
about Super Smash Brothers right now
you're seeing two familiar big wigs
facing off in a friendly battle but this
isn't a simple pre-rendered animation
what you are seeing will be possible in
the new smash brothers games now by
using a Mii fighter anyone can join the
battle I thought about having knee
characters appear in Super Smash
Brothers Brawl but in the end decided
against it somehow at the time it didn't
seem right to have knees punching and
kicking because for this game though
we're not simply throwing them ease into
the fresh we've done some serious work
getting them ready for a fight they're
almost not even means anymore
I think you can tell that the Me's are
going to be just as competitive as the
other characters me fighters will come
in three varieties crawlers fight
empty-handed and prefer to be up close
and personally brawler's are both fast
and powerful sword fighters are weapon
masters they stay cool and calm as they
chase down opponents Gunners are armed
with mysterious arm cannons they have
lots of different projectiles that can
be fired from long-range brawlers sword
fighters and Gunners each type is
treated as a separate fighter or this
and each type can choose four special
moves from 12 options this means that
the mean fighters will have a total of
36 special moves from which to choose
it would take nine regular fighters to
equal that number of moves but I didn't
decide to include knees in the lineup
just so you or your friends could join
the battle see every day I receive
requests for new characters to be added
to the game and now you can use Me's to
recreate any character you like and
fight is that anyone can join the battle
you can fight them anyone can fight this
is your chance to defeat Nintendo's
greats
you